get ready what's the quick breakdown
here once again warzone rated 130
entries thus far 1760 average rating
time handicapped it will be adjusted
according to both players is rating
30-minute tournament anybody could enter
no level experience required game on
tournament on Queen sack round one
where's my little timer there it is okay
just popped into place you've been here
before myself okay I'm gonna go with a
more accelerated version maybe not okay
I got to go here the Knights gonna cause
me problem cos me prom
kill the knight kill the knight kill the
knight kill the knight get rid of the
knight get out of there Knight pawn push
here we go
break it up hit the rook push again
light squares light squares light
squares my pawn doesn't have a light
square bishop pins pins everywhere
check hit the rook break it open here we
go
what next
let's go Queen light square weaknesses
Queen f5 is almost move that camp who
prevented I could take the bishop here
for plays there oh I'm really tempted to
just play there take the rook avoid the
Queen exchange oh I'm on the Queen I'm
on both rooks mate threat that's me back
to tournament to know somebody is free
how does somebody get 300k anyhow let's
try not to figure that out let's figure
out what to do in this position and
figure it out fast
no time to waste here Oh 95 95 is now I
could tuck my queen back fishing fishing
fishing fishing fishing go fish no I
refuse to move
oh here we go here we go get rid of the
defender take the knight h2 there it is
back to tournament land six - I tried
town you tell vanished Elvin here he'll
knows all about it he made that a video
each to killer h2 it's a killer I tell
you
h7 might be a killer as well here we go
get ready get ready don't look away do
not blink whatever you do don't blink
the game could end at any moment don't
blink no blinking allowed kill the
Bishop Castle this side because it's
scary over here where I don't have any
dark square coverage and I have a weak
link here look at this guy what a stupid
pun black them repair them repair those
puns they're repair can test this file
it's getting very dry here dry position
get rid of the knight he's a tough guy
right there ok let's come back let's
chop I have to I've controlled this file
now the queen is there lateral movement
mmm I'm gonna go here I'm not sure why
oh yes I could back up okay I have a
three to two majority to read to
majority this should be good get here
I'm Hana pond I'm watching over these
squares push your majority get going
majority
let's go majority I should have grabbed
that palm maybe let's go majority I need
a king position to this point out it
might not win oh oh no it's not winning
out oh now it's winning the pond pushing
the king got here I was beat but there's
no time to figure it out no time no time
back to tournament land twelve six a lot
of sixes only 112 the big bad wolf
Wolfie Todorov ik Oh fearing the worst
right here sixteen ten quick
designer okay get ready double those
points if anybody's wondering why I keep
clicking on that it means that if you
win you get double and if you lose you
go down a couple points instead of just
one I think right no no no you need to
go somewhere else okay I'm gonna go here
and I'm not sure if it's right I'm gonna
try it though let's go Bishop let's go
Knight and okay well this is a little
scary and I need to watch out for this
square otherwise that Knights gonna kill
me with it the Knight to d5 let's get
rid of this dark spread Bishop let me
try it a couple times put pressure on
this and actually let me do this before
my bishop gets killed no killings no
killing of the bishop and now my knight
where does he want to be let's get over
here
Queen to g5 might be a good spot let's
get rid of this here we go
dark squares dark squares coming up
coming up coming up coming up oh just
take this pot it was free it was a free
pond let's go Knight forks forks forks
pin skewers okay oh I just dropped this
pawn run run run run run run I'm on the
rook got checks and stuff go right here
and it's me right here right here right
here right here
defend this pawn oh oh oh why did I go
there let's try it again I want to go
here now
no repetition give me the open file take
the knight double pawns double up hang
out let's watch over this guy double up
Pass pawn I'm on the rook pressure on
the rook rook pressure little pressure
lateral movement by my queen let's go
clean
here we go whoa a little scary I have to
play f4 maybe that floor give you a
check give a check give a check there's
a check right here oh I can't move my
rook Oh little scary push the pawn here
we go Oh Queen takes rook is there no
it's not no it's not I had I would have
a check as an in-betweener give a check
here and do this before the pawn moves
there's oh it was dropped how much time
do I have
oh they're on my queen sneaky moves they
don't have any time how much time do
they have why isn't their time burnin
come on they should be running out of
time right here wow they're moving quick
why they moving so quick come on run
Pond you're fast you know you're fast
their clock isn't moving what's going on
come on inch your way oh wow they were
at zero seconds that's a lot of seconds
isn't it no it's not I don't even know
what I'm saying
they didn't have any time why wasn't
their clock burning that was like um I
don't know how to describe that an
infant Clark or what I don't know it you
know what I'm saying why they should
have lost their that's what I wanted to
say for so long right there it took a
while but why didn't their clock just
burn man okay let's go push the night
away he wants to go somewhere else there
might be this pawn push get out of there
you capture with my bishop right here
now what there might be a knight move
here actually I'm gonna let's get this
in break it up break it up break it up
break it up break it up deflection hit
the Queen kill the Queen
kill the Queen get the bishop Oh deadly
move that's TKO time TKO I'm on the
bishop dark squares
dark squares dark squares everywhere
Forks on the rookie a check
grab a rook it's probably made right
around the corner right here here we go
very soon made on each - H - H - there
it is H to tell VIN I'll have to call it
alright thirty eight thirty the assassin
it's the assassin right here be prepared
oh the assassin the assassin the
assassin ran away quick resigner quickly
sorry no I wouldn't have this many
points without a couple of really resign
errs here we go and secure my Queens
position move my mouse is ah so bad to
me right here it's from Alice of mine
here we go watching it take them would
be like the okay okay
this is like the um I'm gonna sack this
pond just to get the a file check oh I
should have turned into black oh go here
there would been a fork it's kid tonight
and then take care
it's alright I have a giant pond Center
no there's gonna be a sack right you
have to sack right here otherwise you're
dead right there it is
this is scary
oh I could have I have a block I have a
block I have a block right there I'm on
the rookie they see it whoa
I got a why oh he's dead he's a dead man
he is definitely dead oh man
defense Oh where's the defense oh man
what do i do what do i do what do I do
this is so scary
let's have to be so scary hide behind
this pond just hide behind them Oh
pawn takes pawn push they're running low
on fuel and buy fuel I mean time I could
throw in some time burners uh-oh they're
crumbling crumbling I'm a threatmate
threatmate threat I got me
just by the skin of my teeth and pot pie
is in the lead 64 speedy gonzo speedy
gonzo is playing team black right now
Knight f3 okay let's get to d6 can we
have that happen Oh dark square Bishop
give me the dark square bishop can I
have it oh oh I just dropped upon how
important was that guy oh I dropped
another pawn how important was he let's
kill the knight kill him chase him away
he's dead he has to run to the corner
that's a sad home sad home let's support
this queenside castle incoming queenside
castle oh hang on the knight was being
tricky I'm in a castle even if I drop my
a pawn give me the dark squares
this is scary a little bit because now
there's a bishop there the knight could
take with check
let me give should've taken the tux for
Bishop there's everything okay now I
should probably take here there's some
eights and stuff mmm let me come here
it's a little scary
or a lot scary it's a little or a lot
one of the two let's trade a little bit
get that Bishop out there that's what I
meant to do for a while now he needed to
go the rook is gonna play here oh I got
a tray this Bishop needs to get out of
there that night needs to go so I could
get this pawn get rid of the knight okay
now there's trouble for the King he
should be scared
check pins pins pins hit the pinch piece
now what okay oh I'm in trouble just
move rook
oh my pond is dead cream of time - cream
of cream of time primo primo primo frame
of don't primo so fast now give a checks
checks primo Gil upon frame of frame
move past seventy-nine 6200 you've lost
the game you got nervous using first I
think he got nervous okay be prepared
fasten your seat belts these are bullet
games the bishops cooked cooked bishop
coming up chase the night away grab a
pond he's free the night has to run
scared home it's got to run home or does
he he ran to the edge okay now my
Knights could play to have six a bit
more freely this is needed dark square
weaknesses right here get rid of the
dark square bishop maybe I grabbed the
pond though let me watch this
there's no need to grab this guy my
bishop has a better place to finish your
development capture towards the center
finish development I have a two to zero
majority in the center
my bishop is gonna be killed there's
Bishop here but I can block Oh trouble
trouble trouble trouble the knight can
move
discovery let's block that the Nike
capture I'm gonna sack back it's a sack
the sack bag technique these needs to be
chopped chopped and then a pin chop chop
and then a pin oh it's just a free piece
I was that a mouse slipper I think that
was a mouse Lipper Queen trade Queen
trade coming up push the apon can't be
avoided rook here is covered by my
knight push the ape on let's go run run
back rank mates I have to be cautious of
disjointed puns get right here I'm not
ready to capture now I'm ready to
capture here we go I'm just gonna take
one of them alright now I'm gonna take
um take this one and this take this pawn
and then work myself out of a pin get to
a square where it's defended and they're
out of time back to tournament 99 80 57
15 minutes and change speedy gonzo
resigned last time or did he now he
didn't resign last time I was thinking
of somebody else okay oh I had the
dark-squared I had something brewing
good last time
oh this pond fell last time okay wait no
the night's gonna go where okay right
here oh there's Queen oh there's gonna
be Queen check and stuff ooh scary
it's very scary over here there's gonna
be Queen check get this Knight make a
decision Knight okay now I have this
square covered at least the light
squares are that weak or a lot weak
actually I should have thrown in a check
okay I'm on the rook I have the a file
pawn push here we go f6 f6 coming up I
like that pawn too much to give him up I
want to f6 f6 still f6 right now right
now g7 is the next plan I'm on c5 can
also play here
let me grab this pawn and then I'm gonna
capture with the rook I'm on h6 and I'm
gonna play here and we're next
oh that's Czech and I want to take the
Queen make sure the Queen is off the
board I shouldn't know I probably should
just give in check right there
push the pawn there might be a rough
trade get my king up in the center here
we go
pawn push King capture push push again
get this other guy going 16 seconds 16
ticks push again King up rip check
coming up got the rook and then get out
of the way and clean they resigned back
to tournament 120 how does somebody Oh
120 even with the lass okay
let's go let's go I have somebody to
catch this is right where I want to be I
want to be tracking somebody down I got
it ain't the Bloodhound mode right here
bloodhound mode track him down here we
go let's do it
get rid of the dark square Bishop
actually let me do this he this is a
good double pun okay what's happening
okay I see what's happening my knight
what is it doing
he's stupid stupid night let's come over
here I don't know what I'm doing with
that move okay I have an idea
back up the bishop the Knights gonna
play here one day and maybe I should be
playing this okay that's a good move I
think okay he's being a pain being a
pain that night okay just take this pawn
okay no no no no no I just got my bishop
oh he's lovely piece and he's dead he's
lovely piece and he's a dead man right
now here we go
attack attack you could do it you could
do it fight back I got a bishop I'm
fighting back
oh the tables are turning tables are
turning right now
kill the knight he's a bad man
he's a bad man Oh free Queens for
everybody oh look out
Queens going crazy crazy queen
resignation time 11 ticks all right now
11 minutes left 21 seconds 19 o'clock
Berner Nona fried in action right here
okay
tick tick tick tick tick ah come on a
clock ticker that Queens lateral
movement come on
ah yes back to tournament 141 39 here we
go
11 and change am I gonna get paired up
with the top guy potpie dr. Seuss
I was just dr. Seuss right there okay
here we go
f6 fell in love with f6 that's what it's
all about
here we go you should be falling in love
with f6 if you're not you should oh hang
on stop b5 I'm on c5 I should have
grabbed it while I had the chance you
don't get more than one chance in this
game
here we go get my bishop oh okay now
what is my knight want to do Oh am i
miss pond just take apart oh man hit
this guy I think I'm gonna take that
pawn and then give a check or something
is that working out no not really let me
double up here first my bishop is gonna
get killed
Oh is he gonna get killed Knight there
and then of the Queen problems oh I
gotta do it now I gotta try it here oh
man hopefully this is working is it
working ho g2 g2 is a very scary place
g2 I should be taking this pond but g2
oh I could take it still I'm on this
this guy right here I have enough fuel
enough fuel right here I'm on the bishop
at the end of it kill the rook they're
not my queen
I got the rook I got the bishop what do
I have take here am I made it I'm not
made it oh it's a free rook I got a
matin - threat Queen to f7 then I'm any
time tick tick tick tick tick nine
minutes and change left in the
tournament kill the night I'm not
getting made it oh it's a little scary a
little scary but I have it blocked now
Oh Queen block okay I have this this is
alright I just want to get rid of a
piece give me some peace check and let's
just oh I just dropped my rook
there's no time though they don't have
any time back to tournament a function
that's fine 170 159 come on nine and
change tick tick tick tick tick refresh
refresh refresh close out of that tab in
exactly nine minutes let's go pair me up
no yeah see five I don't want see six
bloomenfeld gambit if pawn push c4 b5
I'm going to try let's try this okay
let's let's try this okay dark square
weaknesses okay well let's do this and
then chase that Bishop around okay takes
or I get b5 expansion the knight has to
worry the bishop is trapped if it goes
back soon right here c4 Trix Trix Trix
Trix Queen b6 as well castle and there's
tricks I don't want to capture so
quickly here oh it's dead it's a dead
man dead man right here
it's a dead bishop no pounds don't do
that come on my phone man Queen trade I
guess there's pressure on this I'm
alright with this come on so it's not
gonna be a quick Lin but it should be a
win still my Knights gonna get chopped
up here alright let's let's go here
watch over the night I can also move and
take the knight let's go here
I got this file open it up I'm on the
night pileup on them dark squares dark
squares get my docks for a bish of doing
something okay I got the night I got
this pawn also if the knight moves take
my bishop I got this with the check and
then recapture my Bishop wants to get
where pawn push how much time just pawn
push and okay right here right here and
if the rook believes the back rank its
mate and he leaves the back rank its
mate so actually I should just push this
pond okay this is me it was a helpful
one dr. chairman 200 how do you overcome
200 there's 17 wins man I had to resign
errs as well 17 games is a lot let's go
come on you could do this okay shut the
door on the bishop get this pawn doing
something maybe get d6 in or something I
was just gonna play G for that would
have been ridiculous okay light squares
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's do this Age 5
I want to get to h5 wait wait wait this
is close to me incoming night right here
for a deadly fork right here actually
this is a mate threatmate threatmate
threat if the Queen moves its main if
she doesn't move she's well it's I got
the Queen you know what I was trying to
say check could I somehow weave a mate
instead of taking the Queen you take the
Queen maybe they'll be resignation
alright sure just taking the pond that
would've did the trick where's the main
come on Knight help out is this me oh
that was me now it's me no it's not take
this rook oh so many quick mates I'm
missing ah come on
me watch I'm gonna get mated okay we got
me coming up making one threat I'm not
missing this next one me Oh
back to chairman $1.99 - 25 minutes and
change let's go ah let's go here I'm
going as fast as I can I promise I
promise it's still not enough it just
it's not enough is it open Sicilian
fishing go fish
Go Fish go fish come on Castle kingside
here we go it's being launched engage
engage he's oh he's back in the mix
don't count me out just yet I'm going
down swinging assassin assassin
Oh quick resigner who's in first Oh - 29
- 24 and change here we go no no no no
no h 5 h 5 h 5 let's go h 2 killer
killer h 2 it's gonna come right down to
the wire buzzer-beaters we're gonna be
having buzzer beaters here stay tuned
for the buzzer beaters ah ok back up and
get rid of that night okay he's not
going anywhere soon okay let's watch
over that I want to play Knight here get
rid of this Knight and then expand on
the queenside no I want this pawn oh
this is good this is good fork fork fork
fork fork I would have played fork right
there if Queen takes pawn I have the
bishop rest his resignation time let's
go resignation time let's just play here
and grab that pond or something open up
the file take with my queen and then
let's play here get that fish up and
then get over here the Queen can't leave
she can't do too much give a check
now I'm just going to come back with my
bishop and then post up right here and
then grab this pond and then give check
and now get let's get my bishop here to
d6 anything and I can still take that
because I have a past pond at the end of
it come on you know this is time to
resign how much time is left I got to
get into our games just resigned come on
don't be a clock burner these are
precious seconds come on precious
seconds right here precious seconds
let's go less than ten nine eight where
are we at in the standings ah 229 I
still have a lead oh oh they moved in I
didn't move okay back to chairman
249 I hope they must have fell back to
49 to 18 if I if I win this one I think
I have it unless there's like three
reasoner's in a row for that other guy
let's go f7 should I hit it real quick -
try this again here we go we've been
here before did I play this guy already
and it was just the same variation f6 I
can't take that pun I think his bishop
check that was the that's the trick
right there okay we're having a queen
trade aren't we is that what's going on
that night needs to go somewhere else
you need to go no I can't but I can't
deal with you I can't deal with you
night oh that's a slick move right there
I like that very cool okay Bishop let's
go oh I just dropped a piece or a pawn
it felt like a piece come on come on I
can't lose this one can i oh it's very
scary look at how scary this is that
light square bishop is gonna kill me ah
let's trade a little bit the bishops
ready to go here
oh man let's come here so I could push
this night away oh that's a sad moved
after mink I tell you what it's sad very
very sad you never want to have to do
that and I did it just then I just did
it right then vision oh no no run King
don't get mated don't get made at how
much time tricky nights tricky nights no
come on don't get made it don't get me
to do something nights hold there
defending like champs I tell you they're
champs oh my king is running for the
hills
how much time I don't have any time get
the rope now I have coordination oh I
got this guy I got the piece back how
much time just take with the check this
come on here pawn push pod push how much
time just burn burn time burn time burn
time oh that's fine back to tournament
269 I think I have it oh I have it I
have it have it I was nervous there on
that one though can can you tell I was
definitely nervous on that one 29
seconds
nervousness there it is first place
confetti
give me that confetti it's what it's all
about everybody is out for that confetti
clothes alright
close that ah man good games oh I had 19
games in 2018 16 right on my heels 269
238 they must have been a little slip-up
right there at the end
and